[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir dann
lasst euch das auf der zunge zergehen
einen apple crumble cheesecake weil ich
mir überlegt aber ich hab so viele
richtig leckeren apfelkuchen rezeptoren
und allgemein rezepte mit äpfeln aber
man zwei so liebsten rezepte nämlich
einfach cheesecake und apple crumble
habe ich noch nicht vereint und ich mach
das jetzt einfach mal und dafür machen
wir jetzt einen boden aus butterkeksen &
butter die butterkekse dafür einfach
einmal das könnte in der maschine machen
und dann in eine schüssel geben weil sie
so eine maschine nicht habt einfach in
einen gefrierbeutel und dann mit einem
nudelholz richtig drauf kloppen und
jetzt lebe ich da die zerlassene butter
lassen das habe ich hätte in der
mikrowelle gemacht gut verrühren und ich
gebe das schon direkt in eine springform
24 cm durchmesser ihr könnt auch ein
tortenring nehmen ich mache das immer
nach lust und laune und dann einfach auf
dem boden hin und schön platt andrücken
[Musik]
so der boden ist schon mal fertig den
geben wir kurz an die seite es ist
übrigens kein no baic rezept in viele
denken gibt's bestimmt nach dem boden
kann nun novak rezept kommen aber dann
könnt ihr tatsächlich auch backen und
für die skate masse nehmen wir uns jetzt
doppel rahmen frisch gräfe das wird so
typisch amerikanisch da gebe ich dann
direkt noch zucker mit dazu und habe ich
euch gesagt dass ich da noch caramelle
gibt wird auch so ein karamell intouch
haben weil ich das passt einfach richtig
gut und da gibt es einfach meine tree
lecce soße das könnt ihr nämlich auch
benutzen falls die daheim habt oder er
macht durch karamell einfach selber
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so schießt masse geben wir dann noch
seine ein bisschen zimt und speisestärke
die speisestärke habe ich ihn zu gesiegt
damit keine klümpchen darin enthalten
sind und zu guter letzt noch die eier
dazu drin wichtig ist dass der allgemein
mit dem teil für diese vorsichtig umgeht
und immer nur so in zehn sekunden
intervall ein rührt auch jetzt die eier
werde ich immer einzeln einem wurden
immer so lange bis sich ein verbunden
hat dann kommt das nächste dazu und dann
ist die cheesecake mal so fertig und
kommt erst mal die seite
[Musik]
jetzt kümmere ich mich mal um die
streusel die sind nämlich super schnell
zusammen geknetet dafür habe ich hier
immer warme butter da gebe ich dann noch
mehr braunen zucker vanille extra stimmt
mit dazu und die ganz genauen
mengenangaben findet ihr wie immer unten
in der infobox und wenn ihr möchtet
schreibt mir doch jetzt mal die
kommentare was ihr allerdings ist apfel
rezept ist
[Musik]
die streusel sind auch schon ready also
es wirklich ein blitz rezept das einzige
wochen gleich warten muss ist die
backzeit und später die auskühlt zeit
aber dazu verrate ich gleich mehr ich
stehe jetzt hier schon mal meine äpfel
und wer tief einschneiden und dann wird
schon geschichte auf den butterkeks
boden kommt dann nämlich unsere
cheesecake masse angeblich die äpfel
obendrauf und die sträuße und dann kommt
auch schon in den backofen
[Musik]
so die sträuße sind auch schon fertig
das hat keine zwei minuten gedauert und
jetzt kümmern wir uns um die äpfel die
habe ich geschält und in kleine
stückchen geschnitten und weil es ja
eher so in richtung herbst winter geht
machen wir da auch noch mal ein bisschen
zimt rein als zucker gebe ich jetzt
nicht noch mal zusätzlich dazu nehmen
wir schon ein bisschen zucker cheesecake
masse und mehr streuseln und in
streubesitz sogar ist sogar brauner
zucker karamellisiert noch mal richtig
schön und sobald ihr das dann habt
einfach alles schichten auf die
wirtschaftlichste kommt die cheesecake
masse dann die äpfel und die streusel
und dann ist auch schon gebacken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
1 2 oder 3 das war erstmal vorbei sind
wie das richtig geht
zwei oder drei was ist das für ein
geschrei
doch ich bin
echt mein leben sind bei starbucks das
jedoch heftig aus also leute
haben sie das ist ein ein apple crumble
cheesecake mit carrier services
komplette story gemacht die leute haben
das nicht so gern ihre kein börsen ofen
kam schon nicht verraten wo mein gott
das waren 160 grad ober und unterhitze
im vorgeheizten backofen für eine stunde
vorgeheizt das hat sich schon so gut
ankommen nicht drauf klar zu sagen sagt
scheiße ist er gut ja das ist jetzt
nicht gespielt oder so wurde ich habe
das dann wirklich das erste mal dass
gesagt ich habe eine idee ich bin ja
magazin ich weiß ja wie das funktioniert
ich mache jetzt einfach und jetzt
probiere ich erst mal ich habe richtig
gänsehaut
so gut schmeckt ist oder willst oder
nicht mehr richtig heran klecker gerade
diese cheesecake masse ist er so
amerikanisch angehauchten in den doppel
ram frischkäse
ja dann nehme ich gern philadelphia wenn
ich ganz ehrlich zu euch der hat einfach
diesen salzarmen geschmack und ist so
cremig dann der butterkeks boden richtig
crunchy album äpfel sträuße und karamell
gekommen
escada ist verein
weißt du was
geil
[Musik]
für steinhaus trotzdem gut gemacht sagt
macht diesen traum gucken nach und
hinterlasst unbedingt einen like wenn
euch das rezept gefallen hat ist nicht
nur so im herbst ja wirklich wert des
wintertraums hammer freut sich
verabschieden ich wünsche euch einen
wunderschönen tag und bis zum nächsten
mal
agenda
[Musik]